[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
april [ __ ] fools
no really it's me
i don't have a good april fool's joke
this year
[Music]
there are too many goddamn fools running
around in the first place i don't know
that we need any more jokes running
around
oh jesus
whoo
ronda santas um
tries to reboot sweet home alabama to be
sweet florida
that that is the ultimate april [ __ ]
fool's joke oh my god
oh everyone's here this morning jazz is
here minus robin here debbie salt lake
is here patty's here linda's here mj
good morning mj steve's here from
facebook linda is here from facebook
gala's here jess says yeah tony saw you
on uh stutter centering john's podcast
yesterday awesome it was awesome it was
fantastic
go check out
stuttering john's page i was on
stuttering john
podcast yesterday it was fantastic go
check that out go check that out
i was on there with richard ojeda
you guys probably know richard ojeda too
good morning good morning good
morning
we have bonehead madness we have a
champion folks
i i don't i don't know if gabe like
planned this to be on april fools day
but
we got all the boneheads on april fools
day
oh
the fools the fools of april fools i
guess
as it were as it were john from scotland
is here
good evening john it is evening in
scotland he says evening from scotland
good evening from scott i don't know
that's not a song
but i'll sing it
tammy is here
kelly reed is here
good morning all paula from facebook is
here you guys are just all over the face
the books of face you guys know we
broadcast every single weekday noon
eastern 11 center on youtube twitter
twitch
every one of them monday through friday
i'm right here screaming into the
microphone for two hours
for the cause of pro-democracy
because the fascists are at the front
door but we're not just on youtube
twitter and twitch anymore we are also
on the books of face
on the midas touch facebook page we're
over there
thank you all for joining us at the
midas touch facebook page you guys know
we are a proud partner of midas touch
and we broadcast from their facebook
page
we also broadcast from our youtube page
twitch and twitter page at
tonymichaelspod
or at the tony michaels just go to
thetonymichaels.com
follow all the links there
all of them every one of them they're
there
you can go wherever the broadcast is we
also download every single episode from
every single weekday on every single
directory
it's a lot of every
singles but every one of them
you uh
apple
google i heart radio even the most
famously boycotted spotify yes we are on
spotify
we are on spotify
lisa thank you very much for the super
stickers thank you thank you thank you
all
if you want to join in on the super chat
and the super dad if you want to give
super stickers or super chat you can
head on over to the youtube channel
again you can go to thetonymichaels.com
the links are in
the list
or you can just head over to youtube and
type in the tony michaels podcast and
you will find us
the show
for show for show for show but thank you
for joining us no matter where you're
joining us from whether it's morning
noon evening night whether you're on
youtube twitch facebook or
twitter
thank you for joining us we got a lot of
tweety tweets and trendy trends to get
to today
uh
we have someone leaving the white house
as the the uh biden economy booms bite
and boom is trending this morning
because the media sucks
the media sucks maybe jinsaki will
fix that up a bit
fix it up a bit maybe she'll help the
media along over there at msnbc
apparently she's leaving the white house
and gonna get her very own show at msnbc
a lot of people are disappointed i'm
sorely disappointed
that we will not watch her
slam dunks ducey in the trash anymore
it's
one of my favorite parts of my day
what the [ __ ]
we don't get to watch jinsaki slam dunk
ducey in the trash chris n is here
our favorite hate watcher chris is here
thank you all for joining us thank you
thank you thank you
and we're also going to talk about how
the republicans think it's a winning
strategy
to be against marijuana
that marijuana that wacky wee boy it's
bad that reefer
reefer madness
oh my god
they really can't stop they can't they
can't help themselves but go back 50
[ __ ] years they can't help it can't
help it no matter what the subject no
matter what the social issue whether
it's political or not
they don't give a [ __ ] wind it back 50
60 years
make america white again i mean great
again
same [ __ ] nonsense over and over
again same tired ass argument same tired
ass [ __ ] stupid ideas
marijuana is a gateway drug there there
is a republican congressman who is a
[ __ ] pharmacist i'm gonna show you
the [ __ ] video he's a pharmacist
he's educated and trained on
prescription drugs
saying that prescription marijuana
is a gateway drug
whoosh
forget about the legal heroine that
they're passing over the counters of
pharmacies
that they're over prescribing
to the american people getting them
hooked
on painkillers get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
it's 20 22 you dumb [ __ ] we
know a lot better than what then
marijuana is the worst thing ever in the
world how many dozens of states
republican states red states
you know conservatives
[ __ ] have medical marijuana
it doesn't
this is really stupid this is really
[ __ ] stupid that we have to even
i don't even want to talk about
marijuana being gateway drug on my
[ __ ] show
i don't
i don't want to do it it's [ __ ] dumb
it's a really [ __ ] stupid thing to
have to talk about but they force us to
have to [ __ ] talk about and here's
why they force us folks here's why they
force us to talk about it it was like oh
well you don't have to give them a
platform they have the platform
what they're using their platform for is
saying marijuana is a gateway drug
hell there's a hell of a lot more legal
drugs out there that are more gateway
drugs
to someone's death than marijuana
alcohol
painkillers
two to top the list
and you're you're gonna [ __ ] make
marijuana the demon again
come on get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] but here we are we have to
talk about it because they have the
platform and they're talking about it
and here's the reason why we have to
talk about it because folks they're
handing us this midterm election
they're handing it to us
their platform is going to be marijuana
bad
that's their platform holy actual [ __ ]
not three
not 93
but
193 republicans voted against
capping the life-saving drug insulin
yesterday
you don't think they're a death cult
think about it
think about it
ron desantis passes
one of the most bigoted bills signs it
in the law one of those the most bigoted
bills makes it to where people are
allowed to be bigots in florida
think about it
think about how they're handing us this
election
they're handing it to us
all we got to do is take it that's all
we gotta do we just gotta take it
we're not gonna take it that's what it
feels like the democrats are every once
in a while oh
not gonna take it
yeah we don't want it yeah you know but
and it seems like they're brazen here
they're convinced they're convinced that
the media
is gonna help them win this
have you noticed that
the republicans the gqp is convinced
that the media is going to help them win
the midterm
because they believe that the media
wants them to win the midterm because
they're like because the media is in the
trump loop still they're still in the
[ __ ] trump loop they can't get out of
it
they can't manage to work their way out
of the trump loop
and they're like there's no way they
don't want the chaos
they love the chaos
what the [ __ ] does the media know really
what the [ __ ] do they know they don't
they don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] they think
they want they think they think their
audience the american people wants them
to parade a bunch of fascists a bunch of
[ __ ] nazis so they can both side [ __ ]
on their shows
well both sides both sides they're
what is the best [ __ ] argument the
republicans have not to cap a
life-saving drug like insulin at 35
what
i'd like for them to go back to their
[ __ ] constituents and try to sell
that idea their constituents
who the drug insulin
saves their lives
and a lot of them in these red states
can't afford that [ __ ]
can't afford it and they [ __ ] voted
against capping it
because i don't know because drug
company profits are so much more
important to them
what in the [ __ ]
we just got off an entire day an entire
[ __ ] day i did a [ __ ] video about
it i did 10 minutes 20 minutes about it
i don't know about [ __ ] ivermectin
how big pharma is in bed and they're
[ __ ] trying to take your money their
constituents
are primed to hate big pharma
they're primed to hate big pharma
and they're voting with big pharma
they are handing it to us folks
they're handing it to us
193
republicans
voted
to to not cap the life-saving drug drug
insulin
they voted with
big pharma go tell all the q and honors
that
go out there
you're on the you're on the books of
face
go out there in them ivermectin facebook
groups
and tell them how 193 republicans are in
bed with big pharma
go on
hurry up we got time to wait
you think that do you think the
democrats gonna do that [ __ ] hills to
the no
hails to the no
the democratic party isn't gonna have
some kind of message that shows these
cue and honors that the republicans are
in bed with big pharma
i mean there it's
big farmer is the mortal enemy
big pharma is the mortal enemy
which big pharma is bad
it's bad for the americans pocket books
it's good for our health care
you got to remember big pharma isn't
just a bunch of private companies it's
also
private companies
providing research at universities and
institutes around this country
it's a big complex system
it really is complex but it really is
[ __ ] simple
to show people
that hey
it's probably a good idea
for the person that represents you
person who relies on insulin who can't
afford it
to make sure the price of it is kept and
your representatives and all the other
[ __ ]
soggy wet white wrinkly ball sacks voted
against it too
we're gonna watch a
video of them voting against it
when we go to the shitless roundup when
we round up all the tweety tweets and
attorney trends
but the biden economy is booming as well
and they
the media you know back to the media the
media really wants again they want
republicans to win
they want to prime this thing because
what they want is they want impeachment
trials they want investigation
they want republicans to run to run
[ __ ] kangaroo courts inside
the house of representatives that's what
the media wants
oh boy baby will that [ __ ] sell
boy will that [ __ ] sell
if the republicans take control and
impeach
joe biden kamala harris and every other
administration officials that they can
get their hands on and they run a
benghazi style commission over and over
oh boy the media oh you talk about
[ __ ]
you talk about orgasms in their pants
they can't help themselves
they love that idea they love the idea
the republicans taking back the house of
representatives
and then putting donald trump a speaker
of the house holy [ __ ] the media loves
that idea
oh my god imagine the headlines every
single day george imagine imagine the
headlines imagine how much profit
they'll be [ __ ] the american people [ __ ]
american democracy imagine how full our
pockets will be
[Laughter]
you [ __ ]
it's what they want that's what the
media wants
they don't just want republicans in
control that's not like their thing
their thing is
they want the stories to sell for profit
that's what they want they want the
trump chaos back they want the trump
loop back
they want it back
that's what they want
and they're like oh man nothing better
than to elect a bunch of pedophiles
miscreants and
criminals to the house of
representatives a bunch of fascist nazis
and then to put grandpa poopy pants who
could possibly federally indict it as
the speaker of the house
that would be fantastic
for us our ratings would skyrocket
[ __ ] media
and and that's the craziest [ __ ]
thing i've ever seen is everyone thinks
that the mainstream media is left wing
and somehow they're [ __ ] part of the
leftist soros cabal
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
if they really were part of the leftist
soros cabal whatever
trope they have for the left
they wouldn't be cheering on republicans
winning a god damn thing not even dog
catcher at this point
nope nada not gonna happen
here they are cheering it on the media
can't wait
they can't
wait
to get donald trump as speaker of the
house
you thought it was just a bunch of
fascists that wanted to speak to the
house hells to the no
hails to no the media wants him to be
speaker of the house as well
that's what they want what else do we
have in the news today
um
we have oh oh yes yeah speaking of
boneheads and april fool's jokes
we have uh
i think it's donny is it donny johnny
donny van zandt
with the
leonard skinnered
doing a song for ron desantis
act like he's some kind of [ __ ] deity
oh my god
this is really [ __ ] gross folks
it's really [ __ ] gross
it's really disgusting to watch
uh the leonard skinner debase themselves
by fawning over ron desantis
who is one of the worst trump
impersonators i've ever seen in my life
did you see this video of him
impersonating trump
i'm gonna show it to you when we go
through the tweety tweets
for show
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] is
impersonating trump
full stop now
i i mean he's doing it for a living it's
it's no longer like a side gig
it's full-on professional
he's he's all in baby ron desantis is
all in on the trump impersonation
i'm gonna show you
don't doubt me
i'll show you
oh
21 minutes into the hour
oh boy
i wish it wasn't april 1st i wish this
was not an april fool's joke but
it is real it is real leonard skinnered
makes a song banzant sorry banzant makes
a song
fawning over that nazi fascist bigot
down in florida
ron desantis called sweet florida even
rob the [ __ ] name from sweet home
alabama you piece of [ __ ]
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we are to the part where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
of the day the [ __ ] list roundup thanks
for joining us here on youtube twitter
twitch and now
from the books of face the midas touch
facebook page as you know we're proud
partner of mind as dutch
thank you to the mizella's brothers over
at mind as touch
i think we're going to show a few of
their videos today actually because they
put one out yesterday
about
almost 200 republicans not being on the
side of the american people
and being on the side of big pharma
that's right that's right uq and honors
the side of big pharma they're on big
pharmacist
that's what that means
you idiots
okay let's go down through the timeline
here
and let's stop right here
this is a great video
speaking of um
insulin
and drugs
and uh
drugs with orgies
jamie raskin here
and here's what i wrote i wrote jamie
raskin
puts cocaine field sex orgies into the
official record
so when you're on the uh
the floor of the house
you can uh
make statements into the microphone here
see that
and it's a it's on official record
official house record
so jamie raskin puts the fact that
madison cawthorne
some people i don't call him this but
some people call him sittler um i don't
call him that that is a little
insensitive to call him sittler so i
don't call him that some people do but
jamie raskin puts madison cawthorne on
blast here
and also in the in
um in great style kevin mccarthy over
their little talk yesterday jamie raskin
puts
the republican
cocaine-fueled sex orgies into the
official record
let's listen
i concede our party is not for the kind
of cocaine-fueled orgies that a freshman
republican representative bragged about
this week
but we do understand that their
marijuana prohibition laws don't work
for our people but in any event
oh
you gotta love some jamie raskin he just
does not give two [ __ ] anymore does he
he's like oh you want you want the words
cocaine fueled sex orgy into the
official record you goddamn right i will
you god damn right i will he does not
give two shits anymore he's not screwing
around with these republicans he's one
of the democrats out there that is
willing to pick up the messaging and run
with it
um if you're not talking about if you're
not talking about how these people took
away people's insulin
so that they could have cocaine-filled
sex orgies you're not doing it correctly
you're not doing it correctly all you
democrats on the hill if you're not
talking about how 200 republicans took
away
their constituents insulin so that they
could have cocaine-filled sex parties
you're not doing it correctly
you got a message it's called politics
now look
there's two things that are going on in
this country government or policy is
different from
politics
and messaging they're two different
things see if you don't do the politics
and the messaging and win elections
you don't get to do the whole governing
and policy thing
like you can talk about all you want at
[ __ ] town halls and on your [ __ ]
website and and all kinds of [ __ ]
social media videos about how this line
item and that line item and this line
item and that's fine if you're in a safe
[ __ ] district
if you're gonna slam dunk your [ __ ]
district but if you're in a competition
with a [ __ ] fascist [ __ ] that [ __ ]
stop talking about line items and bills
start going after them
this is the this is the battle that
we're in fight the politics win the
election and then we can talk about line
items and bills
you think you think a republican a
fascist a nazi in this country a gqp
nazi a let's go brandon nazi
is gonna have a discussion with you
about making sure that that that
prescription drugs are affordable for
the american people get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] they want 193 of
them not three not 93
193 of them voted against making insulin
affordable for the american people so
that they don't die
got it
it's a death cult
here is a buddy carter buddy carter from
georgia
buddy carter from georgia
i don't know at first district of
georgia someone needs to look into that
[ __ ] district and check their [ __ ]
heads
examine their heads
to see if they're in a [ __ ] time
machine
here's buddy carter talking about
marijuana if it's the 1940s or 50s
mr speaker as you know i'm a pharmacist
oh ho he's a he's a pharmacist did you
hear that mr speaker by god he's a
[ __ ]
pharmacist well prove us why you're such
a [ __ ] then
i know addiction i know
and i've studied addiction
why why because he's a pharmacist
is he such a [ __ ] expert on a dick
addiction this sounds like another this
sounds like another [ __ ] sex
cocaine sex fuel orgy moment from the
republicans why is buddy carter an
addict
he's so [ __ ] he knows how he's a
professional he's an expert he's an
expert by god he knows addiction when he
sees it
i mean he's been there done that you
don't know how many cocaine sex fueled
orgies he's been to
i guess buddy carter may be holding sex
orgies in washington dc
for a bunch of gqp addicts
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
listen to this garbage at the end
i can tell you yeah marijuana is nothing
more than a gateway drug it is 2022
folks
that's that's the year it's april 1st
it's april [ __ ] fool's day
this has got to be an april fool's joke
right
that buddy carter is standing on the u.s
house floor
talking about how marijuana is a gateway
drug
what the [ __ ] are you talking about man
and you're a pharmacist
and you haven't read up on medical
marijuana yet dumb [ __ ]
jesus christ where are you a pharmacist
at
stay the [ __ ] away out of that [ __ ]
pharmacy i wouldn't buy cold medicine
from buddy's pharmacy
but he knows about addiction i mean all
republicans really they do
they're addicted to a lot of [ __ ] aren't
they they're addicted to a lot of
[ __ ] garbage
they're addicted to their their
billionaire donors their corporate
donors
they're they're [ __ ] completely
[ __ ] addicted to donald trump
and the chaos that comes with him
they're addicted to fascism they [ __ ]
and loved to tell other people what the
[ __ ] to do
they're addicted to hating
oh my god that's
that's one of their [ __ ] pastimes
isn't it
addicted to [ __ ] hating so much so
that they don't even want you to say the
word gay and if you do say the word gay
they'll prosecute you or at least
someone you know a private citizen will
[ __ ] sue you
they're addicted to thinking about other
people's genitalia and bathrooms
absolutely [ __ ] obsessed with it
i mean you talk about [ __ ] addiction
baby holy [ __ ]
obsessed
obsessed with what other people's
genitalia is in a bathroom
i mean by time it's all over with
they'll have [ __ ] bathroom inspectors
do you remember when we were having
conversations in this country about
[ __ ] school shootings and they wanted
to have armed guards at all the schools
they're going to have genitalia guards
at every bathroom from here tell kingdom
gum you won't be able to go in the
bathroom unless you expose your
genitalia to a republican somewhere
because they need proof god damn it
they're obsessed they're addicted
this is a fascist addiction and they
think marijuana is the gateway drug
it's power that is your gateway drug
buddy carter
pack your [ __ ]
and go back to [ __ ] george's first
with your delusional
50 year old [ __ ]
[ __ ] the [ __ ] down and shut the [ __ ] up
let the adults in the room do the
[ __ ] adulting this is ridiculous
i'm gonna come back to this video later
of don rickles i think it's important
george han posted earlier
let's see what else do we have here oh
here's the here's here's the um
so ron desantis went to a birthday um a
birthday party apparently i don't know
what this is i think it's a birthday
party where he's impersonating trump
no i'm dead serious i don't know what
this is
he's maybe it's a fake campaign rally i
mean doesn't seem like a lot of people's
there so maybe it's a maybe it's kind of
like a uh
an attempt at a trump nazi rally
you know there's tens of people here
there's tens of people that showed up to
watch this trump impersonator
i'm just saying
i'm just saying you know if he's so
[ __ ] popular in florida why is he
only talking to tens of people really
doesn't make much sense but you know
what do i know
what do i know
but this trump impersonator
one
let's make this bigger
you gotta see this [ __ ] watch this guy
worked hero prevail accomplished more
than anybody thought was possible and i
would say we've accomplished more in
this state since i've been governor than
any governor has been able to accomplish
here or anywhere else
he really is working on the cadence
he's working on the hand gestures i mean
he really is he's working hard down
there in florida ron desantis is working
hard i mean he ain't got the [ __ ]
extra long stupid ass tie on red tie on
but he's he's he's gained at least 50
pounds he's gained at least 50 here
he's got the [ __ ] hand motions down
he's really trying to get the cadence
down he needs to die his [ __ ] hair is
what he needs to do if he's going to be
a trump impersonator you really don't
want to walk around with the dark air
it's been a long time since donald trump
had any kind of resemblance of dark hair
you really want to you you want to
bleach that [ __ ] ron
and and again again you got to put on
the [ __ ] tie you look you don't look
like a trump impersonator without the
[ __ ] stupid-ass red tie that hangs
down to your [ __ ] knees
you might want to put lifts in your
shoes so you lean forward a lot i mean
i'm just i'm just i'm just trying to
give constructive criticism here to the
governor of [ __ ] florida if he's
gonna do an impersonation by god he
better do it [ __ ] right
i mean he's doing the whole fascist
thing perfectly
oh he's got that part down perfect
hating people and being a [ __ ] bigot
boy does ron desantis have that part of
the trump impersonation down pat
the whole white male fragility victim
[ __ ] got it down pat
uh he's got that part of the trump
impersonation down one hondo percento
hundo p he has that part of the trump
impersonation down pat but he really
again he needs to dye his [ __ ] hair
he needs to put the [ __ ] tie on he
needs to he needs to [ __ ] make sure
that he's got the lifts on you know so
he's leaning forward a lot but boy look
at these hand gestures i'm going to mute
this because i don't want to listen to
this guy but watch the hand gestures
here bop
boop he even does that he even does the
the uh that this thing this thing you
know he's doing the little wheels and
the woos and the house and the the bing
bing bing bong boom boom boom you know
what i'm talking about the trump does
watch watch and he does the he does the
uh the lit
the finger across
the swoosh finger the swoosh
finger
and then he does the i'm gonna put my
finger on it
right there
oh no i'm sorry right well where is it
he does it he does it there it is right
there
that's what he does
and he even even does the voice
cadence okay he's the voice isn't down
he doesn't have the trump voice yet
he doesn't have the trump voice yet but
he's got the cadence down
so he's getting there you're getting
there ronnie you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's pretty [ __ ] simple i tweeted
this earlier well let's read the tweet
that i have
on this video
i said that the trump and pert this
trump impersonator cost twenty dollars
an hour and all
of your liberty
like why don't people get this this guy
is no [ __ ] hero
to freedom
if
think about it folks think about it ron
desantis supporters if he's willing to
take away
other people's liberty what is going to
prevent him from taking away yours
when you cross him
huh
a [ __ ]
when an idiot
okay uh i i didn't do um
there's another ron desantis
and ron desantis appears in the bonehead
madness championship now you guys know
the um
you know who won but then we're not
going to give it away just quite yet
we're not going to give it away just
quite yet we're going to work towards
that and we're going to do bonehead of
the week in the second hour
we're going to do the bone head of the
week in the second hour today but i
still have some more videos i want to
show you here
um
oh
this video here i'm really kind of feet
up court
this really this video here i thought
this was great this really um
i wanted to tweet maga2024
with this video because this feels like
what it's gonna be
um
and this is a homemade zipline and this
lady is going to zipline across
and they're going to think it's really
fun and really cool but watch what
happens this is this is my
like if there's a video that is going to
describe
maga 2024 this is it feet up court two
hands two hands go go go go oh
excellent form
and then at the very end
feet up court two hands two hands go go
go girl
[Music]
don't let go
that's what i think that's what i
envisioned for manga 2024. um
speaking of um sex orgies did you guys
hear
that um
[Laughter]
the king the king of coke
the king of coke roger stone uh decides
to go on info wars on alex jones show
nate
oh man
you can't make this [ __ ] up
you can't i mean i would love to
actually you try watch this
this is a video that gabe found um of a
republican congressman
well that's the january sixth one we
want the sex orgy one where where did
that one go
where did that one go
um there was there was a um a video put
out by a united states representative
it's an anonymous video
talking about um let's go to gage
profile and see when you find it you put
it at the yeah here it is um talking
about this uh
coke f coke field orgies
and listen listen to the video to the
part about roger stone
and you try to make this [ __ ] up and
then we'll go watch the roger stone
video watch this let's just address the
sex elephant in the room shall we the
republican origins in dc are definitely
a thing and so is the cocaine i mean how
do you think we speak so much pork into
a bill in the middle of the night but uh
fun fact though roger stone has some of
the best coke come talking primo powder
and speaking of coke madison cothrin's
like a goddamn hyena after a few pumps
we actually gave him a nickname
ever since his russian spy wife divorced
him he's become kind of a loose cannon
at the recent orgies which are normally
like if eyes wide shut west wing and
[ __ ] my dad says had a baby but
after a while cauldron started bringing
creepy guys around like jim jordan matt
gates who are
god
awful so naturally we kicked him out and
that's why he's talking [ __ ]
actually uh i am late for one of our
weekly orgies you want to come
uh there's a there's a disclaimer at the
end
and gabe put out another one of these he
found sorry he found another one of
these anonymous videos
from an anonymous uh staffer
about the seven hour gap but on this the
end of this one it says our lawyers want
to remind you that this is a joke based
on what republican madison gothard said
on a podcast about orgy and coke and
bites he got from colleagues in dc
a lot of people thought that these
videos are real i'm not gonna say if
they are they aren't here on the tony
michael's podcast
i'm gonna let you decide that you decide
but you've seen the part about roger
stone uh that gabe made up there
or found this video which some may or
may not be made up
but listen
and again i we try to do parody we try
to do satire we try to make you guys
laugh
but these people just step all over it
here is [ __ ] roger stone on alex
jones
show
talking about cocaine sext orgies listen
firsthand that madison cawthorne is
telling the truth and he needs to be
given the benefit of the doubt and i
think you have to question
why kevin mccarthy is so anxious to
cover this up why is he so anxious to
silence this junior member of congress
why are all these rhinos jumping out of
the woodwork attacking him what are they
hiding what do they have to hide were
they at some of these parties is that
that's my question for them
here's roger stone
with the the primo powder king
surmising that the sex orgies do exist
this is what happens when they get in
bed with these dumb [ __ ] when
they have someone like madison cawthorne
an insurrectionist a seditionist in
their caucus and they won't they won't
remove him from their caucus
this is what happens he goes on podcasts
and says dumb [ __ ]
and then the dumb [ __ ] that you don't
want people talking about is the the
crazies in your party who are running
things roger stone is donald trump's
best buddy
okay
roger stone isn't just a some [ __ ]
weird ass supporter of trump he's his
dude
he gave this [ __ ] a pardon
in a court case in a conviction where
donald trump is named in the [ __ ]
indictment and individual one
it isn't roger stone is just some weird
ass [ __ ]
supporter
cokehead supporter of donald trump no
they're dudes
they're [ __ ] dudes
and here is
the uh the local weird stuff orgy expert
weighing in on what roger stone just
said
alex jones himself the weird stuff orgy
expert he i know i'm that's not my title
for him that's what he says
well listen
he had a super hot wife too i mean what
do you think people are going to do i
mean this is ridiculous i've been
invited to these things
what what
can you even [ __ ] imagine so now now
we know now we know
that there ain't a [ __ ] chance in the
hell not a [ __ ] chance in hell that
that these are these
cocaine field sex parties are part of
the democratic blood sucking cabal
not a [ __ ] chance in hell no [ __ ]
way will you convince me ever in a
million years
that there are politicians on capitol
hill that would go to any kind of party
where this [ __ ] is i
no [ __ ] way if i showed up somewhere
at a and a cocaine field sex orgy
i mean if i was invited to one and i
decided to go is what i'm saying
and i knew that this [ __ ] was
there no [ __ ] way i'd leave in a
heartbeat nope
sounds great cocaine sex orgy all sounds
cool alex jones not cool
not cool and here's the reason why he
tells you why here you go i haven't gone
to them because i don't want to be you
know whatever blackmailer i'm not into
that i'm happy but i mean i've been
invited not just that's listen what he
said i don't want to be blackmailed
because that's what he would do if he
would go to him is he would blackmail
other people they tell you what they're
gonna do they tell you who they are
like they say it out loud these
[ __ ] roger stone alex jones
steve bannon
donald trump
all these fascists ron desantis they
tell you who they are right out in the
open they don't hide it they don't say
the quiet part out loud kevin mccarthy's
like jesus christ madison speed bumps
as that anonymous united states
representative says his nickname is
speed bumps
keep it down a bit stop talking about
the sex field orgies that we invite alex
jones and roger stone to stop talking
about that [ __ ]
but listen
listen to the other hint
of weird [ __ ]
that alex jones projects here listen
been invited not just to those i've been
invited to the really weird stuff not
with kids or anything but
i've been invited to the really weird
stuff
you remember that these people are the
ones roger stone and alex
jones and all these [ __ ] weirdos on
the right
info wars steve bannon traitor tv types
they're the ones they're the ones
calling democrats crazy cabal and blood
sucking and all that [ __ ]
and he's projecting right here oh i get
invited to the really weird ones the
really [ __ ] weird ones not not not
the child stuff
what
what
boy if you really do believe these
people are projecting
you really have to worry about that
statement with alex jones listen to it
i've been invited to the really weird
stuff not with kids or anything but i'm
a kid
gotta have a caveat on there
wanna have a disclaimer to make sure
everyone knows
what i'm talking about
people
the reason why
we have to sit here
on my show
and listen to alex jones
and roger stone
talk about cocaine field sex parties
weird orgies you know not the ones with
kids and stuff
is because of trump
and because there's people out there who
still believe that [ __ ] idiot isn't a
buffoon
and they think he's going to be some
kind of great dictator a putin like kim
jong un like dictator where he's gone
he's going to
there are people who believe that donald
trump is going to allow them to kill
liberals
go watch the [ __ ] video of charlie
kirk at one of his events and the guy
standing there says out loud when are we
gonna be able to start killing us some
liberals
they say it out loud
the reason why this [ __ ] exists the
reason why we're in this crazy timeline
the reason why we have to deal with
madison cawthorne marjorie taylor green
and lauren bobert
paul gosar
and the rest of the really the 193
[ __ ] republicans who voted against
the american people getting it getting
affordable insulin
the reason why we have to deal with this
is because of bigots
bigots like ron desantis who have power
bigots like marjorie taylor green and
lauren beaubert and paul gosar
chip roy of texas thomas massey
these [ __ ] bigots
if you want to know
how we can fix this
is we have a mint term coming up in 2022
we have a midterm
and they're giving us everything they
[ __ ] we need
everything we need to beat them
can you imagine if they have to [ __ ]
explain
in a debate on a stage with the democrat
why
they
have you been invited to sex orgies
congressman
would you go to a sex orgy
trump
candidate
well i mean all your all your people who
you love who you shake hands and take
pictures with roger stone alex jones
donald trump they all talk about sex
orgies are you going to attend these
trump sex orgies
they're giving it to us
they're handing it to us and all in the
same [ __ ] breath they're saying that
big pharma is the enemy they've got
their [ __ ] constituents to believe
that big pharma is the enemy with the
goddamn vaccine and yet they're on the
side of big pharma with insulin they're
handing it to us folks
they're participating in in in deadly
cancer culture bigoted cancer culture
when they cancel the word gay and you
can't say gabe they're not just doing it
in florida
they're not just doing it in florida
it's not just a florida thing
they're gonna do it everywhere and all
these states are gonna try to out
florida florida trust me they're gonna
have bills and they're to try to out
florida florida
and they're going to try to out taxes
texas by taking away women's liberty
they're handing it to us
it's ours for the taking
all we have to do is call them out on
this what do you want what do you want
do you want someone in washington
do you want someone in washington who's
going to concentrate on policies for the
american people like getting them
affordable insulin
or do you want people going just cocaine
field sex orgies
making sure that they're canceling words
like gay
and they're making sure they're on the
side of big pharma what do you want what
do you want
they're handing it to us folks all we
got to do is pound the drum
pound the drum pound the drum pound the
drum pound the drum
they always do this uh this [ __ ]
they do this to us every single day all
day every day they've got they've got a
hundred [ __ ] shows out there
and half of them are in the top 100 in
podcast and tv and radio shows
that pound the drum every single day the
pro putin pro trump pro cocaine sex
field
pro big pharma pro big oil
there's another [ __ ] thing there for
they're for big oil oh they love it
oh you doubt me
they [ __ ] love big oil they love it
they love it that's why they blame biden
see the oil companies are the corporate
oil companies here are gouging the hell
out of the american people and gas
they're gouging the [ __ ] out of us
gouging us gouging as gouging us
gouginess and the republican party loves
loves that the entire country is blaming
biden so do the oil companies folks the
oil companies love that the american
people are blaming bite for gas prices
because that means they're not on the
hook
they can they can keep gas whatever they
want no matter what crew drops to no
matter what their production costs drop
to no matter what their transportation
costs drop to they don't give a [ __ ] if
the american people are gonna blame
biden by god those gas prices are going
to stay high
and the american people are so [ __ ]
stupid
that they that they buy it hook line
sinker
hook
line sinker
they buy it
they're like oh yeah biden's fault that
it's four dollars a gallon
and what they don't know is if they all
collectively turned around
and went oh it's not his fault it's the
[ __ ] big oil companies
he actually
put millions of barrels of oil from the
reserve to draw down the price of crude
oh
which draws down their production cost
which if we [ __ ] knew that if we had
a half a [ __ ] brain would pay
attention for two [ __ ] seconds and
realize and realize that there's not a
gasoline button on the president's desk
if we [ __ ] did that if we did that
then we would hold the [ __ ] oil com
the corporate oil companies accountable
in the public discourse and they would
be forced to lower the price of gasoline
at the pump
but they don't do that
and that's why republicans are pro-big
oil
they're
corporate oil folks they love it
they love it because big oils against
biden
and so is the republicans
they're handing it to us
they're [ __ ] handing it to us and
democrats won't talk about things like
gas prices why why republicans in the
oil companies are [ __ ] forcing the
american peoples to overpay for gasoline
at the pump
they're doing that
biden's doing everything he can to force
the oil companies we have free market
capitalism here i don't know if you're
aware that
we have free market capitalism here but
the one thing that biden can do is
release reserves flooding the market
which drops crude which drops their
production cost of gasoline which means
if they keep the price of gasoline at
the pumps high their margins go up and
if their margins go up they fill their
pockets full of [ __ ] money folks
and if the american people continue
continue to blame the person who's
trying to drop the price of gasoline do
whatever he can the button he has on his
desk to drop the price of gasoline which
is to release reserves millions of
barrels of crude of reserves into the
market
if the american people continue to blame
the wrong person the oil companies can
keep gouging you they can keep gouging
you that's right go out there in your
communities your churches your grocery
stores your schools at your family
dinners tell them what i'm telling you
tell them in front of you they're like
oh biden and gas presses tell them what
i'm telling you
it might just [ __ ] click
it might just oh yeah oh that makes
[ __ ] sense
it's not the [ __ ] president it's the
oil companies it's it's the gasoline
companies
you don't even have to show them the
price of crude liberals do that [ __ ] all
the time they want to get a graph out
like oh let me show out okay uncle bill
let me show you a graph let me show you
a graph to prove you wrong uncle bill oh
and he's just like well that's just fake
news that's just fake news you found
that on the interwebs and that's just
fake news no explain to them
uncle bill it makes sense right that the
oil companies when the price of crude
drops
when the price of crude drops that their
production costs drop
yeah that makes [ __ ] sense
we're a free market capital you're a
free market capitalist aren't you uncle
bill you goddamn right i am
red blooded capitalist
well then you would understand that the
price of crude drops the price of their
production drops which lowers the price
of gasoline right
it really is [ __ ] simple folks it
really is [ __ ] simple
but the republican party is pro
pro big pharma they're pro-big oil
they're pro-sex orgies cocaine-fueled
sex orgies
they're pro-cancel culture
they're pro-al and
and
they're pro reefer madness
they're handing it to us
absolutely
[ __ ] handing it to us all you got to
do is go out there and
convince the people
you your friends your family your
community members
you just gotta convince them of the [ __ ]
that's real okay let's watch
let's watch this video from midas touch
again you know we're proud partners of
might as touch but that's one reason why
i want to play this video but the other
reason why i want to play this video i'm
going to remove the banner too uh
because i want you to guys this is a
this is a c-span video or part of the
footage is from c-span a lot of people
don't know that c-span even exists now
c-span is pretty boring when you watch
uh floor votes now you can watch the
process happen of actually how a bill
becomes a law you don't have to watch
the the schoolhouse rock video you can
actually watch how a bill becomes a law
and c-span does their best it again it's
very boring but they do their best to
explain how the process works and what
the process is that you're seeing in
front of you
but in this video you should go watch
csp you should take you should take your
time go watch c-span and learn how
government and policy works
and then learn why the the politics of
the government part you know the
government and politics are two separate
things we talk about that here
politics and government two separate
things they're not the same thing two
things you got the politics which gets
you into government and then you got the
government part where you have to
actually do policy like they're doing
here in this video
but if you want to go watch c-span
you can go watch and see how government
actually works learn a thing or two
it's not complicated and then when you
learn those things you can you know give
that information to other folks that you
know but here is the video that uh midas
touch made it's a hashtag democrat save
lives
democrats deliver because the
republicans want to destroy people's
pocketbooks over insulin apparently 193
of them let's watch
there should be a final passage on this
bill lowering the cost of insulin for
americans
[Music]
on this vote
the a's are 232
the nays are 193.
the bill is passed
it really is simple
democrats deliver
republicans destroy
the price of insulin in this country
they want to destroy your pocketbooks
um we had bone end of the week
we have it coming up we're going to do
your regular bone end of the week poll
we're also going to go through bonehead
madness
here very very soon
let's see if we're uh we're almost ready
here
are we getting close
i think we're i think we're gonna be
close here we may have to
let's give uh let's give our executive
producer and co-host
gabe
a message here
okay um but the bonus of the weak pole
we had will smith madison gothen and
donald trump on the bonehead of the week
bowl
you guys see here um what the what the
final
the final results were so we're gonna go
through the bone of the week course
oh it's kind of obvious
why these people are on the bone of the
week it's not really a big big [ __ ]
secret especially the first one
um and as important as that event was
and this week and how much people talked
about it um i'm i'm really proud of you
guys of who you picked here um i voted
for madison gotham the candidates you
see my check mark here
you see the check mark here that
indicates that i on my account voted for
madison gothorn
um i i went back and forth between
donald trump and madison gothard and
i'll explain that more
i'll explain that more
when we get to bone end of the week
so don't stick around we're coming into
the second hour we'll be getting the
bonehead of the week very soon probably
the next five or ten minutes
is when we're beginning bonehead of the
week we're also going to go through
bonehead madness as you know we've been
playing
bonehead madness here on the tony
michaels podcast for the last week
uh and yesterday it was revealed that
possibly someone
someone may have been
someone may have been stealing our ideas
i'm not going to say who or what lincoln
project
[Laughter]
we went through this yesterday gabe is
very upset about the bonehead madness
man
the lincoln project did a video called
maga madness and they lifted the exact
bracket that you guys voted for it
wasn't just the bracket like that he
came up with
they lifted they lifted
what you guys voted for like he put some
of the you know we we chose
who the cop who the who the head-to-head
competition would be and then you guys
got to vote who won some of those races
but they lifted
they lifted some of your votes from our
bone madness thing and put it into their
video manga madness i'm not [ __ ] you
and we're trying to get rick i want to
get rick wilson on the show to talk
about this of course i want to talk
politics with rick wilson anyways i want
to have rick wilson on him i
love to talk to rick
about
the lincoln project
but specifically
our our executive producer here gabe
sanchez is very very interested
in how lincoln project
um finds their content because not just
in
and i'm sorry it's not it shouldn't be
funny tony it's not funny
and gabe gabe is very very very serious
about this and
it is a serious thing
we work very hard to do this content and
you shouldn't be stealing other people's
ideas it's just not a thing that should
happen
you shouldn't be stealing other people's
ideas
and it's not just this one time like if
it was just this one time maybe we could
say it was a coincidence
but gabe has had this happen several
times where the lincoln project has
lifted his ideas
um they lifted two videos
within hours of him posting it believe
it or not
not just not just like weeks or months
later hours
hours they lifted the idea
so i again i i'm sure there's a
reasonable explanation for this
somewhere somehow
that they could explain
why
why their video which was a great video
i i'm not saying the the manga madness
was a bad video i think it was i think
it was a well-produced it was a funny
video
and the the premise of the idea
of manga madness is hilarious that's why
we did it
that's why we thought it was a great
idea when gabe came up with this idea he
came up with this idea probably back in
january is when he first mentioned this
to me now he said hey i want to do in
march i want to do a bonehead madness
where we have like a bracket system i
said okay that sounds really complicated
but it sounds really funny and it sounds
really fun for you guys to vote on all
these games that's what i was excited
about it's like oh you guys get to vote
you guys get to practice voting
i actually like that that's a fun thing
right so they
they get to fight back and forth right
you get the fight
back and forth you guys get the vote it
would be great i was like oh this is a
great idea
now i i doubted for a while how it would
work and how it put together but he did
a beautiful job gabe always does a great
job he thinks these things through very
very meticulously he's very into detail
which i am not as you know i'm more the
spaghetti at the wall type person
but he's very meticulous very detailed
um he came up with the graphics he he he
really he really did his homework on who
the boneheads should be in this
competition
so he worked he worked really hard
i mean he has a whole spreadsheet with
all the the i'm telling you
it wasn't just fly by the seat of his
pants here
so the idea was fantastic and lincoln
project
apparently thought that the idea was
fantastic too
so much so that they would do a video
called maga madness which again the
premise of the video is hilarious
because it's our premise
[Laughter]
uh it's gabe's idea
oh my god
so
rick wilson if you're listening uh buddy
rick
come on the show
i know there's probably a good
explanation from the lincoln project
from you
of why it seems
of why it seems
that
that you lifted our idea bonehead
madness i'm sure there's a perfectly
good explanation of that what appears to
be theft
um everyone stick around we're gonna go
to break
and we will be right back
and get into bone ed madness very soon
in the second hour
right after this break stick around
we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one in your absence i
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and i even seen my
cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears tammy
[ __ ] him
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
sticking around we're gonna get the
bonehead of the week here really quick
[Music]
very fast i think gabe's gonna be
joining us here really soon uh there
were some people here in the uh comments
here on facebook and saying boned connie
connie says bonehead what is that i
think that's what you're asking connie
so bonehead of the week we do this poll
every single week
every single week we do bonehead of the
week if you go to twitter and follow us
at tonymichaelspod
you can vote in the bonehead of the week
poll every single week
and then at the end of the week and the
second hour on friday which is today
today
second hour friday
we go through your vote
that you voted for bonehead of the week
right here on the tony michaels podcast
because we're here every single weekday
monday through friday oh
excuse me 11 central 12 eastern 9
pacific
noon eastern every single weekday
youtube twitter twitch and now
minus facebook page
but on fridays in the second hour
because we do two hours every single day
not one but two hours
every single weekday in the second hour
of our friday show we go through your
vote of bonehead of the week here is an
example of the bonehead of the week poll
right there on twitter
who is the bonehead of the week we list
our contestants you guys get to vote
so again go follow us on twitter at
pod even if you don't have a twitter
account yet and you just want to get one
just to do the bonehead vote i would
encourage you to do that it's a great
way to practice voting a great a great
way to practice democracy
and again every single friday in the
second hour just like today we go
through your vote
we go through your vote um all them
let's see it looks like all the stuff's
coming in um we may have uh
we may have our co-host gabe sanchez an
executive producer
and um
uh
victim victim of a theft gabe sanchez
joining us very soon
uh let's see if we can
get gabe in but that that that's what
bonehead of the week is does everyone
um
does everyone uh understand the bonehead
of the week out there on facebook i know
i know we have a lot of new listeners
so if you go over to and maybe maybe
just maybe we can um
we can coordinate with midas to see i
don't know does facebook do polls you
guys know i don't know this i'm not on
facebook enough you guys out there on
facebook
do they do polls on facebook kind of
like they do on twitter where you can
post a poll i don't know
i have no idea i don't know if you can
or not
is that a thing
hello
thomas says if donald trump is on in the
poll he he's he's winning always ah
thomas i actually believe
i don't know i think there's actually
uh thomas says they do polls over on
facebook i don't know
i don't know if that's true thomas about
the uh trump always winning
um i actually think
that um
i think he's lost a few times believe it
or not i know that sounds weird i know
you wouldn't you know you think oh no
there's no way that's possible
it is possible it is true i think donald
trump has lost in the bone end of the
week now i believe one person um up
until last week that was undefeated
was marjorie taylor green
i believe um she was undefeated until
last week
she was defeated
um
by tucker carlson i believe is who beat
her out
it's my and it's a real sad situation at
marjory taylor green is no longer
undefeated in the bonehead of the weak
pole now it was during bonehead madness
to be fair i guess to marjorie taylor
green if you can
if you can be fair to her
um it was during
the bonehead madness event not the
not the bonehead of the week the weekly
poll which you're seeing on the screen
right now
but apparently they do do polls maybe
maybe i'll talk to the suits
over at midas touch i'll have to write a
formal letter over to the suits
to see if we can get the bonehead of the
week pull over on the facebook page that
way we can collect the votes together
may be difficult though because then we
got to figure out who wins hmm
i don't know across two platforms uh
looks like we might have uh our our
co-host an executive producer if you can
give me a thumbs up when he's ready here
um
he's he's on the road he's traveling
he's in an undisclosed location
i think it's because he's hiding from
lincoln project uh gabe sanchez how are
you sir i am good how are you you're a
little frozen but you're good you're
your mic is working there you go there
we go oh yeah perfect um it looks like
you're you're hiding it's super zoomed
in
it's super zoomed in oh my god hold on
and you're freezing up but yeah you know
it's it's it you know
you're big you're huge yeah
holy moly there you go
are you better
yeah but you're still freezing a bit a
bit but your mic's working yeah which is
you know there you go ah hey hey there
there we go
there we go okay don't move oh i'm
frozen again well no no it's all right
it's all right don't don't get too
frustrated about your video again
i'm hiding in a bunker away i mean i'm
in a bunker hiding from uh from rick
williams lincoln project i threw some i
threw some [ __ ] at them yesterday and
i've been getting a lot of hey no i
haven't heard anything next well you
know actually actually you have been
it's funny because earlier i played um a
video that you had found on the internet
of this anonymous united states
representative and then there's also
another anonymous video that was posted
it's crazy these guys just keep coming
out of the woodwork right right and and
they almost look the same and sound the
same almost but you know
here's the thing
when there's a silhouette
and a distorted voice everyone sounds
the same and everyone looks the same
right it's the same gabe sanchez style
haircut the same silhouette that kind of
i mean they kind of look like you i mean
they kind of look like you like hey look
that's that's your uh opinion oh okay
you know what you don't got one a day oh
they definitely got one i think that
might has actually retweeted the one
that you did on the seven error phone
gap and there were some people that were
really upset like really pissed off
about this video they were here
there was a moment
when i posted the video when i thought
oh should i do another legal thing at
the end of here
uh
and was like nah i mean like this is all
stuff that's like been said right people
know that it's gonna be fake right
you're like i would i would hope so but
then here's the thing so within the
first few minutes people are like oh
hahaha this is funny this is great this
is it's hilarious yeah i think it's
funny you know objectively it's funny
well right but i mean but i mean you
wouldn't have done it if you didn't
think it was funny right i'm not gonna
make stuff that isn't
funny you know right well well who knows
here's the thing i might make here's the
thing i have a lot of crazy like dumb
ideas on my head and whether i like
actually executed on them or not yet to
be determined i probably already have
and people might be like oh that wasn't
funny at all and yesterday was a was a
prime example of people thinking it
wasn't funny even though it was funny um
of people responding right away and
they're like why would you ever share
this has this been verified and i'm like
what are you talking about
i like it there's no official markings
it's not like is it not clear that when
i say
oh
trump ordered so many diet cokes he
broke the red button it was kind of like
watching one of those mice in an
experiment get to press the button and
get the treat
it's also weird that they believed it
also when i say
it's like i swear the [ __ ] brahms
doll is based on kushner like do you
think these are i mean like who knows
maybe people are going to say this and
we live in a reality it is real maybe it
is well here's the thing in the in the
other video the first one that you
released mj says that uh gave a super
chat here for your genius
with the blue heart
thank you
because we we do appreciate the gabe
sanchez genius here but the first video
that you released the one with the legal
disclaimer because you do say you do
make some accusations in that that are
jokes right but some of them appear to
be true because you make a joke about
roger stone having primo coke and then
he proceeds to go on alex jones's show
info awards and we showed this earlier
well it wasn't even that it was later
that night right like he had sent a
telegram
message out and it was it was basically
being like i'm in communication with
madison what's telegram first off
because a lot of people aren't going to
know that right so telegram is uh you
know it's like kind of been overtaken by
the right wing they use it as their
messaging platform to be like if you
want to get the inside scoop on what's
going on i will message you my followers
and people like listening in
on um
on on things that are kind of abreast
right right and so what did he post on
this social media type site so that one
i'd have to look it up exactly but he
would say it was in communication with
let me see if i can find yeah with
madison cawthorne and right and it was
something on like the
uh
the comments that were made
from kevin mccarthy
let me see yeah because because if we if
you've seen the other day because
the best part about the whole [ __ ]
cocaine fueled orgy things is kevin
mccarthy decides i'm going to talk to
madison carthurn to bury this thing
right and it only [ __ ] fueled it even
more like it's only giving democrats
more fodder jamie raskin there's a video
jamie raskin this morning on the floor
of the house putting cocaine field sex
orgies in the official record on the
house floor but the
the craziest part about it is like my
vision of kevin mccarthy uh talking
quote unquote to madison gothard about
sex field orgies is he's like so where
are these things like because i haven't
been invited like what who's inviting
you to these things and who are these
people at these orgies and apparently
it's alex jones and
roger stone that's apparently who it is
so i found a couple of these telegram
messages uh here i'll send you
you got a link
yeah
and then and then we'll get to bonehead
because we gotta we gotta do bonehead
really quick and it's going to be really
quick because we're already talking
about this yeah but then we're going to
go to bonehead madness as well let's
let's copy this let's see if we can
bring this up on the screen
[Music]
that's one of them i feel like there's
other ones that are out there
uh based on
okay so here here it is um
and this is this is uh roger stone
taking a screenshot
of molly young fest uh actually tweeting
of course ryder stone wants to be
involved in this um because zachary post
here just when you thought the madison
gother and coke orgy saga couldn't get
any more strange roger stone just wrote
on gab congressman madison gothard just
told me that not react re retracting his
claims about drug field sex orgies among
dc elites and then roger stone retweets
the retweet of the retweet i guess i
don't know
or no he he telegrams it yeah yes
uh molly young fass is just upset that
she's so hideous
what that no one will have sex with her
even
when they're high
and if she's hustling
zachary
parisa
let's just say she's
barking up the wrong yeah i'm not i'm
not saying that roger stone was puffing
that primo powder oh my god this message
guys lost his mind is kind of out there
it's kind of like a stream of
consciousness it's one you know it's
like when you have that inflated ego and
confidence and you think that everything
you say is right and can't be wrong and
and this is one of those moments where
i mean look here
yesterday
or two days ago or two days ago yeah
yeah two days ago uh is yeah is just
upset that she's so hideous that no one
will have sex with her even when they're
high
also using the wrong there uh
zachary patrizo let's just say she's
barking at the wrong tree i mean if if
he's hitting bumps a coke here you know
like
you got to give him a pass on the their
thing like you know i mean i i i do the
you're your thing that they yeah every
once in a while but but really if you're
bumping coke and you're high as [ __ ] and
you're really you know you're riding
riding the cocaine train which roger
stone apparently is because i mean they
get invited to these parties all the
time he told alex jones this and alex
jones even was like i get invited at
these parties whether he does or not or
whether he was like
i want to i want to see him cool guys
right they're really weird ones even so
yeah yeah exactly
and not only that here's the other thing
is that in that video i believe it was
that video
uh
alex jones talks about how its eyes wide
shut yeah and it was a joke it was just
a joke i made in the video right right
it was like his eyes wide shut and
they're getting and they're saying
they're claiming they're getting invited
and that's what it is right exactly so
listen guys i try my hardest to just
make the [ __ ] up
and then it you know i guess enough
times throwing [ __ ] at the wall i'm
bound to be right most of the time now
well it happens it happens all right
let's let's go to bonehead let's do a
really rough transition here boom yeah
whoa
yeah bonehead of the week i thought you
did that banner guys
you hide in the bunker away from rick
wilson and this is what happened you'd
be you'd be surprised what little you
can do in a bunker when you're by
yourself oh well you know especially
when you got shotty internet you know
uh for all those not listening out there
again this is bonehead of the week
bone of the week where we go through
your vote
your vote here's the vote
democratic system here that's right
that's right we believe in democracy so
let's start bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to bonehen this week's bonehead
of the week
we have special edition of bonehead of
the week this week not only do we have
our normal poll
which is not surprising who won and i
was surprised how close it was though
and we'll explain that but we also are
going to go through bone head madness
that we just went through and who the
champ is the champ the champ the champ
which i actually
i was kind of disappointed but it is
what it is the vote is what it is there
was no rigging there was no there was no
rigging of the machines um there was
there was
there was no um bamboo ballots or
anything like that none of none of the
cyber ninjas nonsense
it was fair a free fair election and we
will report the results
as they came in and as they were
um even as disappointed as i am in the
results
well i mean you know i really i wanted
marjorie taylor green to win this
conference yeah i wanted marge madness
right now i really wanted i wanted it to
because we can't say march madness it's
not it's not march madness yeah yeah
cause like ncaa and cbs that come after
us right so we can't say march madness
can't say it because that's not what it
is it is madness right right it's it's
it's a madness it's not march madness
it's bonus it's in march it was in march
yeah it was it was in march yeah yeah
right i mean we we wrapped it up in
march right like the poll ended in march
i believe right yeah well yeah well yeah
the uh well i mean officially i guess
right right we start we we started the
championship game and the game was one
in march
but we i wanted marjorie taylor green
and she really looked like she might
wait i honestly thought you know she was
kicking butt those first two rounds
and ron desantis came in and just
stomped her ass yeah who knew that's why
that's why the cinderella story of ron
desantis because really he is kind of
the cinderella story right yeah he's so
underrated he's such a [ __ ] putts and
but he came in he he signed the don't
say gay bill he's been running around
impersonating donald trump so hard he's
he's getting really good at it yeah yeah
i saw him earlier you were assessing the
hand
right and he's he really he needs to get
the [ __ ] tie down i mean he's gained
the weight so he's a fat slob now but he
really he needs to dye the hair the lean
we need the lean right he needs the
shoes he's got to lean in but he but he
really does have the bigotry down oh
yeah
hating people the hate the bigotry the
misogyny the buffoonery he's got that
down [ __ ] pat it is beautiful his
impersonation on that level but the
physical import he really needs and and
he's got the cadence down the hand yeah
but he's got to work on the voice the
hair yeah and the outfit it really needs
to be it's almost like you know the
longer they spend in the same state like
he's just like
absorbing
those properties you know right and he's
just becoming
right
do you think it's like do you think it's
it's like uh in marvel where uh uh bruce
banner becomes the hulk and they merge
oh right yeah yeah it's like ron
desantis and donald trump are like
merging into one
yeah
yeah
you know or it could be it could turn
out to be like that scene from the fly
um
if anyone hasn't seen that you should go
watch that with jeff goldblum great
movie uh but i think it's like that
scene for the fly where it's like you
know he tries to teleport the fly gets
trapped in there dna
mixes what how is that again how was it
it goes
oh okay okay and then by the end of the
movie
he's just a big [ __ ] fly you know
right so who knows he might be like a
like a
another trump or he might be worse than
a trump you know so you think like it's
a clinical transition then who knows i
mean there might be some like physical
kind of changes that happen obviously
like you know he's like face-off type
stuff you know i mean you know
i'm just saying no i mean there was that
conspiracy that joe biden and donald
trump did do a face-off uh situation
which could totally be real right which
is hilarious because
if trump is actually the president right
now and and
and it's just to face that switch right
right
uh
then he is really disappointing to all
right i know he's really [ __ ] i
i mean i guess you should be thanking
trump for those gas price hikes right
right right right right it's uh it's
kind of ridiculous but you know it is
what it is yeah um so let's let's go
speaking of trump um let's go to the
poll here we had uh will smith of course
we know why will smith was on the poll
we're not even going to go through that
again we did a whole thing on monday if
you want to know mine and gabe's stance
on will smith i think it still stands go
back to the monday show you will see it
there it even has will smith in the
title download it on apple spotify
google or go to the youtube channel and
and watch it there um madison cawthorne
we know why he was on the pole i kind of
greased the skids here i tried to give
the sex orgies a head start i voted for
matt i wanted to vote for donald trump
because the reason why donald trump's on
here is because he loves putin and he's
trying to get russia uh a time that
there are our actual war enemy
he's trying to get them to help him uh
win an election which he's not in uh
yeah i mean sometimes you gotta
you gotta grease the wheels for speed
bumps you know oh yeah yeah
but in in the video
and um cause you know a lot of people i
don't call him this a lot of people call
him sittler oh yeah yeah i've heard that
you know it's kind of it's kind of i
don't call him i don't yeah i don't call
him i don't call him hitler either right
um but speed bumps that now that that is
a new good nickname
speed bumps here um i don't know is
that's in the video that you get but um
um that's fantastic but donald trump is
on the bowl here thanks kathy yes kathy
with the super sticker the super sticker
thank you very much
for your support again you can get in
the super chat if you're on youtube just
go over to youtube and type the tony
michaels podcast and you will find the
podcast youtube page subscribe sub
sub and then go down to the comments
like and so whatever you're supposed to
say on youtube yeah you know okay okay
so donald trump here won the poll 42.2
percent um which is not
i mean it's not really surprising that
he won yeah someone said earlier that
anytime he's in the poll he would win
but i don't think that's uh that's not
true no yeah i don't think that's true i
don't i don't i think there's been a
time where
um he's been in the poll a couple he's
won i think two out of three times he's
been in the poll so we'd have to go back
and look yeah yeah
he's not a shooter we'd have to send it
to the booth for them to review but
right right but marjorie taylor green up
until up until this week was now she is
undefeated in bonehead of the week i
believe but yeah she is not totally
undefeated where she did lose in bowden
madness in the very final hour against
ron desantis
um but we have will smith madison
cawthorne and donald trump we also have
a few other characters here um this week
you know we guys we do a dishonorable
mention and the desirable mention is
kevin mccarthy now you think he might be
the hero here but he really did
he really did draw more attention to the
sex orgies by actually um having a
talking to
with madison cawthorn i mean
you would think like insurrection um him
going around talking about how you need
to get violent you need to use your
second amendment remedies you know all
these things that madison gotham are
these despicable things that a congress
person should not be saying should not
be doing should not be engaged in
you would think
saying that putin are that zielinski is
a thug and
um holding up putin uh paddling around
with folks like um mike flynn and
uh roger stone and alex jones apparently
i guess that's where the sexfield orgies
come in but you would think you would
think kevin mccarthy would have enough
sense to question him on those things
but he really he really wanted to make
sure who was getting invited to these
sex field orgies apparently
which you know i i feel like it's uh
what is it this the streisand effect
right the barbra streisand effect where
it's like you don't want to talk about
it but and by addressing it you end up
causing more people to talk about it
yeah you know that's exactly what
happened and i think the republican
party is like
guilty of this
on repeat occasion right and we call it
projection a lot of times right exactly
and that's what it is right
right and they're they're coming to it
and they're saying
don't don't focus on this don't look at
it and then realizing that by them you
know trying to deny it or them trying to
skirt away from it they're actually
drawing more people to look into it and
be like this is good
right
maybe there's something to this whole
cocaine-fueled orgy thing
like when you have when you have when
you have the guys who you would like
okay
in dc like you think about it it's not
just politicians in dc there's lobbyists
there's lawyers there's staff members i
mean there's all sorts of people in dc
that are that that aren't just
politicians right right that have
something to do with the federal
government
and then you think of people like roger
stone and alex jones you're like yeah
those dudes definitely if they had a
chance they're going to a sex field orgy
like 100 like totally uninvited like i
look at those guys as uh
the people that hear
like
uh from a distance that there's
something happening and then they're
like oh [ __ ] we got to go to that party
right right typically it might be like
matt gates and jim jordan that just like
show up to the party uninvited but in
this scenario i think it very much is
uh
uh roger stone and alex jones where they
hear this and like oh [ __ ] dude we gotta
go like let's go get a [ __ ] six-pack
and like maybe a bottle of skull and uh
or like a
pack of skull and a bottle of vodka or
whatever and they they show up to the
door and they think they like ding-dong
and they show up and they're like you
know password and you know they say
password do you think there's a password
to the sex orgies i think there's a
password and they say the password
because they heard the password and it
might be like cuck or something i don't
know maybe it's like venmo i mean it
could be like what like a venmo handle
what your venmo handle is maybe right
exactly
and then
uh
yeah and then you know roger stone is
like oh hold on i got joel greenberg's
and he like flashes joel greenberg's
venmo oh okay and then yeah he's like oh
entered and then they walk in and then
people are like
wait
who invited these [ __ ] i think that's
what it's like they show up uninvited
sneak their way in and then while all
eyes are like focused on the grand thing
they like as they enter the hall or
whatever this like sex dungeon is all
eyes turn back on them and then they get
kicked the [ __ ] out so that's the
closest they've ever gotten to these
weird [ __ ] sex parties i think is
them sneaking in or showing up at the
front door pressing the doorbell to be
like i'm trying to get on here for the
party on joel greenberg credentials huh
yeah yeah well you know you know this
this is all
um coming full circle too because
for for [ __ ] i don't know how long q
anon's been accusing democrats and
hollywood oh yeah of having a uh
you know a blood sucking cabal and all
this weird stuff that they [ __ ]
believe and here you have republicans on
the hill having to have a conversation
with an actual sitting member of
congress and you have [ __ ] weirdos
out there like roger stone and now jones
coming to his defense and probably
probably madison catherine will make an
appearance on steve bannon's trader tv
to verify that no
uh kevin mccarthy didn't
didn't tell me this or didn't tell me
that
maybe maybe we should have made mccarthy
alpha cuck but we did make him the
dishonorable mention
uh for his barbra streisand moment as
you as you put it um
but we do have an alpha cuck which is
very interesting this morning we
actually slid this one in at the very
last moment i mean even we were chatting
last night and you know it's all we
didn't know
the dishonorable mention in the alpha
cup can present themselves in the last
few hours of like even five minutes up
till we die exactly
and and our outlook is johnny van zant
um do you want to explain who johnny van
zandt is and why
why this bone hand is the alpha guck of
the week and while he's cucking
so johnny vanzant is the uh
the untalented brother what is it donny
ronnie ronnie right rocky ronnie
or someone in the rest of the group is
also named donny so there's donnie
johnny and ronnie okay sounds like a
good guy ronnie van zandt is the
original right of leonard's
now johnny is like the wish version of
his brother okay
oh he's definitely the witch.com version
of something and uh it's like here you
show up to walmart and you're like i
want to
be like i want the ronnie van zandt and
like oh we're all sold out and then
they're like well well we do johnny we
got the johnny uh and like oh is that
like the same thing and they're like
[Music]
you remember you remember the movie
jingle all the way when arnold
schwarzenegger and sinbad are trying to
fight and they're like
you want the ronnie band santa
oh you missed it and here's the thing
they're like they're like oh they're
like yeah we we got uh a johnny van zant
and they're like oh yeah yeah my kid
won't know the difference and they're
like
just go pick it up in the discount bin
right right and then he knows the
[ __ ] difference right and then he
goes over there and they're like
actually we're giving these away now so
if you you don't even have to pay us
we'll pay you right yeah if you'll take
if you'll take 10 of them we'll actually
give you some money just yeah
well you know credit just just to give
people a little bit of history on
leonard skynyrd leonard skinner does use
the confederate flag originally in a lot
of their in a lot of their um shows they
would have the confederate flag behind
them um and they had it they had the
famous song sweet home alabama of course
and i think that's this song that we're
going to talk about why uh johnny
manzant is the uh is the alpha cuck um
why
uh
sweet homeowner because he called a
sweet florida which is kind of gross
that he's using the whole sweetheart
beverly but ronnie vanzant for those who
don't know ronnie vanzant was not a
bigot right ronnie vanzette was not a
bigot um he actually uh
was for equal even though they did have
the confederate flag at the time um
before ronnie uh tragically died um but
but uh they
leonard skinnered at the time ronnie
vincent the talented ronnie vanzant the
original lead singer the original
of leonard skinner not the wish.
um he actually he actually um
was not a bigot his brother apparently
though
has bought into bigotry hook line singer
by um cocking a song for ronda santos so
what is this song is this did he like
write this song because i i seen part of
the video
i'm making the assumption that he did
write the song
like without without uh you know
i think this is a solo project
but who knows maybe he hired someone to
write the lyrics but i don't know like
i'm not sure if one's giving him more
credit or not it's just funny that this
is actual news coverage
because the actual song i don't want to
play the actual song [ __ ] this song i
don't want to play this song um uh aaron
here let's see i think this is this the
one i want to play this one
yes it says worst cult personality ever
um
is this the i think this may be the one
that we want to play let's watch this
i had to turn the music off i don't i
don't i don't even want to have the
music on so you see here that he's
really cooking for
oh yeah it's really gross it's really
gross it is gross you guys can go watch
this video um i'm not going to play the
video because uh it just gives vanzant
the the opportunity what i find funny
about this is that it says new song
highlights the leadership of governor
desantis if someone can point me to said
leadership i will love to read about it
because
i haven't seen any sort of leadership
when it came to covid relief
protocols uh just healthcare also taking
credit for infrastructure like what
leadership has been there where the guys
actually stepped in and taken care of
like do does leadership like try to
scold kids who
uh who are wearing masks in the backdrop
of some uh of like a photo opportunity
is what it was like no
that's not what leaders do leaders don't
uh make their constituents or others try
to feel bad and shame them
constituents don't let you know
people die
of a
uh what has now become you know through
different protocols vaccine masks and
distance like things that can be
prevented he just said ah [ __ ] it it's
spring break every day down here in
florida right well [ __ ] he said that not
a hundred not three not 93 193
republicans
voted against the life-saving drug
insulin to be to be affordable for
america which i don't understand because
that's something that is a huge argument
of donald trump lowered the prices of
insulin which he never died
chris in christian has been in the chat
all [ __ ] day talking about hit chris
where are you chris
chris you're out there chris was in the
chat earlier talking about how donald
trump had it at 35
so if that's the case if that really is
the case and these republicans are
voting for it
is the idea now that republicans are
anti-trump
yeah i don't know i would love to hear i
would love to see chris's response here
right here okay
explain this
you believe that donald trump lowered
the cost of insulin that's the big
platform move on big pharma and going
against them then why would republicans
almost unanimously
be for big pharma
why would they why would they say you
know what let's let big pharma hike up
the prices so people who actually have
this and can't afford it will no longer
be accessible do you want to answer
chris do you want the answer gabe that's
because republicans have always
have always been for big pharma they're
for big pharma they're for big oil
that's why big oil is remaining to gouge
the american people
because the republican party has
convinced the american people that it's
biden's fault and as long as the
american people are are consistently in
polls blaming joe biden for gas prices
oil companies will not be held
accountable and they do not think
they'll be held accountable and they
will continue to gouge you they will
continue because you and your stupidity
is blaming the wrong person you're
directing your aim in the wrong
direction
and you need to be directing it at
republicans
and by the way by the way donald trump
didn't lower the price of insulin
yep he did not lower the price of
insulin also the claim when i think it
was yeah it was donald trump that said
insulin is as cheap as water oh full
[ __ ] [ __ ] it is that is not true and
i see chris over here saying uh
uh uh i don't believe it it happened
what's the argument chris what we're
talking about is the fact that
republicans voted to allow
pharmaceutical companies to raise the
price of insulin right
so explain that what happened there
right right 193 of them
all of them pretty much not three not 93
190
posted up
with big pharma they are in bed with big
pharma by the way uh yesterday or was it
the day before iver mechton was trending
again because there was a big huge study
about how i don't know
and the craziest part the [ __ ]
stupidest [ __ ] argument i get because
i i think might just put a clip of me
talking about ivermectin on um
we did on instagram and the biggest
[ __ ] argument was well i cause i say
in the clip
big pharma makes ivermectin and they're
like oh it's generic i'm like oh my god
who the [ __ ] do you think makes generic
drugs do you think there's mom and pop
stores down the street that are
producing generic drugs it's big pharma
who invented ivermectin it's big pharma
who owns the patent of vibramectin even
in a generic setting it's big pharma who
is making and manufacturing ivermectin
rather it's the [ __ ] patented one
that merck had or the generic one you
dumb [ __ ] it's
capitalism
pluck your head
out of your ass
and believe your own [ __ ] [ __ ]
your own boneheaded [ __ ] talking
about boneheads of the week so uh
i guess to come full circle here um we
do have uh donald trump will smith and
madison gothard on
the bonehead of the week donald trump
wins the bone of the week i want to get
the bonehead madness here um so we can
get to the champion there but not only
did donald trump win
donald trump wins the bonehead of the
week but he brings along with him
kristen and all his supporters who
believe all his [ __ ] chris we do
appreciate you being a hate watcher here
please don't stop uh and and please
comment um with your and please send us
some uh send us some money too yeah yeah
absolutely get a super chat we want to
make sure that we continue to have a
place for you to come
and be
and be a donald trump supporter inside
the polls
and a putin supporter along with it with
donald trump trying to collude with
russia and collude with putin to win an
election that hasn't even started yet
let's do this let's give donald trump
his due
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that
thanks to the trump supporters i guess
and donald trump for chris says
yeah i know you love me um you know
chris we love having uh anyone here who
wants to watch we love hate watchers we
love trolls as long as you don't get
bigoted and racist and ridiculous in the
comments uh we do appreciate that you
don't do that chris so um you we believe
in freedom of ideas and freedom of
speech and you have the right to be
wrong yeah that is the right thing yeah
you have the right to be wrong a lot of
the time
and right now
you are
oh man
holy [ __ ] you are wrong it's incredible
thank you kristin uh for being our our
our local uh punching bag today um
so let's get to that's bonehead of the
week
we gave donald trump as due um let's
talk about the bonehead madness thing
for real quick we got about 15 minutes
left in the show i want to give the
champion their due here
um it's not surprising really who won i
was disappointed but
um let's let's um i guess at the end of
the day it was all about who's the
bigger fascist right well i think so
yeah yeah i mean that that could be it
well who's more pro-putin maybe um
because that was really the theme of the
bonehead of the week poll i think the
reason why people voted for donald trump
is because the guy was supporting a
murderous dictator i mean he's been
calling for a murderous dictator to help
him win uh back the the united and not
only that
russia and putin said our partner trump
we want him to be the president united
states so that way he can be a murderous
dictator all around the world and they
can together
together in their loving relationship
they can destroy democracy yes partners
they can destroy democracy all around
the world so that way uh there is no
human rights there is no uh there is no
equality there is no equity there is no
liberty they don't want liberty why
would they want liberty liberty
threatens their power well they only
it's not liberty for all but it's
liberty for some yeah right i mean they
want to have the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people right which isn't
liberty right exactly you know we say
that on the show every single day every
single weekday that that theme song
starts with the phrase the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people
is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] so let's
uh let me see if i can pull up the uh
the podcast page here um
here it is
here we go here's the graphic let's pull
it up here here is let's pull this
banner down here oh you've got the you
got the um you got the championship okay
yeah well here here is here's the the um
the final round it was um tucker carlson
and ron desantis
as it were in the bonehead championship
now again
um ron desantis came in at the last hour
i mean the very last hour to to box out
marjorie taylor yeah and i really
because of that gabe i really did have
ron desantis pulling this out in this
final championship game of bonehead
madness against tucker carlson i really
did i yeah i thought the same i thought
ron desantis was really going to take it
home you know with all the [ __ ] that
he's been pulling but right it turns out
that
people looked at tucker carlson as a
bigger threat you know i i think that's
what happened i believe that we had a
situation where in the championship game
um it was just the threat
of a fascist who is supporting putin
in this war on democracy i really think
that was the most boneheaded thing now
not to say that ron desantis isn't part
of the machine in this war against
democracy because he definitely he
definitely is a person who loves to
oppress the rights of other people and
take away people's liberty i mean all of
it he wants to take away all your
liberty if you live in florida so much
so that he'll get ronnie or ronnie i'm
not running johnny donahue bonnie
whoever the [ __ ] this guy is this
vanzant [ __ ] discount discount
ronnie ronnie wanted you know yeah just
a discount manzant uh character to do
sweet florida and do a song for his
campaign so much so yeah because
remember you know ron desantis is the
guy you know the republican party is the
party that says you know freedom of
speech right first amendment that's the
one we we only care about the first and
the second amendment all the other ones
go [ __ ] themselves this is the fifth
amendment and then i need to protect
myself as to not incriminate wow but
really they don't even understand those
three amendments right exactly but the
first amendment they say freedom of
speech you know uh big tech shouldn't be
able to suppress our voice they we
shouldn't be able to silence us we
should be able to say what we want and
be as big as we want right you should be
able to say and do whatever you want
because that's [ __ ] america and then
they're like hey you're gay no [ __ ] that
don't say it don't say it yeah don't
even say that you're don't even if
you're thinking it just
right quiet and they're gonna they're
gonna start passing don't say gay bills
all around the country i wouldn't be
surprised and i'm going to look into
this week because i want to start a i
want to start a thing here where we find
the next don't say gay um and i don't
know if we make a segment on it or
something but we're going to find
because they're going to do it they're
going to do it folks now that florida's
done it there all these red states are
going to try to out florida florida and
these republicans are going to try to
out florida florida so they're going to
have don't say gay bills all around the
country to really gear up for the
midterm of 2020 to prove to everyone in
the country why they shouldn't be in
charge but ron desantis here really
disappointed me
really [ __ ] disappointed me i wanted
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] to win so bad
oh my god i wanted him to win i know i
know but i voted i voted for myself i
really thought was ron ahead at some
point
uh
i don't recall i looked at it when it
first went live ron was i guess in the
first like 10 or so votes that i saw he
was obviously winning but then i
i checked out and i didn't want to you
know it was one of those like can't look
at it right now i'll come back to it
when it's over
because i think he was ahead at some
point because i voted for ron here you
see the check mark here indicates that i
on my account voted for ron desantis
um because i believe
um what he is doing by legislating it's
not just his opinion see i get that [ __ ]
a lot you know in the comments of things
uh videos we post stuff we say they'll
be like oh you're just trying to silence
someone's opinion like okay
tucker carlson has the right to be on a
broadcast right i'm not going to review
that and really as long as he's not
saying things that endanger people which
he's bordering on right he has the right
to say his i mean i don't know i would
say that in some ways tucker carlson has
already endangered lives by the things
that he said which is like either
pushing disinformation around covid
right or it's pushed the narrative that
we should be pro-russia or pro-putin
anti-ukraine because they're you know
it's hunter biden's laptop and it's joe
biden and it's zelinski and they are the
evil people in the situation
laptop is an evil person by the way it
is if you're not aware hunter biden's
laptop is the biggest national security
threat yeah that we have and it's
hacking the moral code right of this
country you know did you know that the
uh hunter biden's laptop and they
actually are going to release a
statement
later on next week to the actual i ai
the artificial intelligence code that
runs jared kushner did you know that
what i'm just saying i'm just saying
breaking news right here on
you hunter biden laptop people really
are [ __ ] dumb okay so
but you are right that tucker carlson
probably has said some really dangerous
things
but you do have the right in this
country to be a bigot you have the right
in this country to harbor
racist bigoted um ideas fascist ideas
you do have that right in this country
it is called freedom now what you don't
have the right to do though in this
country is to take those ideas become in
power and then legislate them and put
them into policy that is not a right
that's not speech anymore that's not
your opinion and anyone out there who
[ __ ] says any of these laws that
these [ __ ] fascists are pushing and
trying to legislate is opinion you are a
[ __ ] bonehead and you should be in
the bonehead madness you should be on
the bone end of the week because you are
a [ __ ] bonehead when you think that
policy
when policy
is opinion it's not opinion anymore
right it never was never will be when
you're legislating it so that is
important that's why i felt like that
ron desantis had a really good chance of
winning this but obviously everyone
and maybe i should have known this that
if if tucker because you know as the the
late great george carlin says
uh [ __ ] tucker tucker sucks um you know
maybe i should have known from the very
beginning that tucker carlson was gonna
win this thing yeah i
you know i i think
it's tucker is a
is a threat in many ways to
uh democracy oh absolutely and
the the way that he uses his platform
for evil and not good
uh because rarely if ever have i seen
him say something in the positive light
to say like hey the country's doing
pretty good good job right or like this
is a great example of this or it's
always been how
democrats bad republicans good you know
this person's bad this person's good
this person's evil you know that type of
narrative which you know obviously is
totally fair to say on the left as well
in terms of how
you politic against each other
but tucker carlson
also remember
had to go to [ __ ] court and had the
lawyers at fox news say that no one
who like no real sane person should
believe the things that tucker says
because they said that in in in court
like yeah on the official
and he got out of the lawsuit that was
brought up against him because they said
actually tucker carlson isn't news he's
entertainment which i would say is fair
to say for most of fox news um that
they're not actual right the only person
we don't claim to be news here right now
we're just commentary
we're just commenting on things and
here's the thing tucker carlson has an
entertainment show he doesn't have a new
show okay the only person the last
person had a new show on fox news was
chris wallace right okay that was the
last person and that's gone bye-bye
right and he's gone because he was like
i couldn't take this [ __ ] anymore i had
to go and i was like i'm surprised you
even stayed that long honestly
so tucker carlson is uh you know spreads
propaganda disinformation and also is
anti-democratic that's the those are
like the three pillars and if you want
to throw a fourth one in there for like
bigot go right ahead but those are the
pillars in which tucker carlson
sits up like that's where he stands
that's where he he holds his show and
his voice on those pillars to be like
these are the things that i'm gonna
spread
some random conspiracy [ __ ] it let's do
it you know
so you're so you're saying it's tucker
carlson doesn't even have to make it to
the credential of bigotry to be such a
[ __ ] bonehead and win bonehead
madness that is yeah he's got other he's
got other pillars to lean on wait wait
wait way more [ __ ] than he does
well tucker carlson congratulations on
winning the bracket here um he is the
bonehead madness champion and i'm i'm
disappointed um on a couple different
levels number one that uh ron desantis
maybe didn't beat tucker carlson but
it's your guys's vote we go through the
vote just like we go through the vote
and the other thing i'm really
disappointed that marjorie taylor green
didn't pull out on ron de santa so we
could call it
merge
merge menace merge madness
with march madness marge madness that's
the beauty of the bracket baby well you
know maybe there's always next year
there is always next year i'm sure next
year um during march sometime yeah we'll
probably do like a bonehead madness
bracket thing you know it just so
happens to be in march look if other
people out there lincoln project want to
come and uh partner together instead of
stealing ideas right you could just ask
us if you want to do a video just be
like hey you want to collaborate on
something you want to use the branding i
think it was a great video the manga
madness it was a great video based on
our content it was fantastic yeah it was
great they were like hey look at that
final four bracket we should definitely
use that they were like oh they are like
people they went against totally yeah so
lincoln project we really are flattered
that you uh found our content i mean
that's what they say right they're you
know it's a it's a form of flattery
right when people copy you so
thanks lincoln project for the third
[ __ ] time
and by the way uh shout out uh rick
wilson if you'd like to come on and
explain
yeah um why you like gabe and and the
podcast content so much like bonehead
madness we'd like to come on and explain
we would welcome you on the show please
live we would do a recorded interview
live however you want to do it right we
would love it i want to talk it out
because here's the thing and i told tony
this yesterday
that those pieces of content are
approved okay by certain people in your
organization whether it is you at the
top or someone else right someone's eyes
are on it which means that you at the
top just like any big company right you
could throw other people under the bus
but you are responsible because you gave
the final sign off on that content so
whoever at [ __ ] lincoln project is
stealing these ideas okay
i want you on the show yeah and if that
means rick wilson needs to to own up to
those sins of someone else then bring
him on right rick come on we'll we'll
talk to you buddy we love to have you on
to talk politics and
to get to the bottom of why you love
the content here so much and why it's um
such a hard thing to get just to get a
message to a guy like hey we like your
content let's um
let's let's we want to do a video based
on bonehead madness well that's that's
bonehead of the week thanks for joining
us stick around for announcements we'll
be right back after the song here
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that was a pretty good
transition yeah that was a pretty good
transition that was great i don't know
we're getting better at it we're getting
better at it uh thank you everyone for
coming to bonehead of the week today and
all the new listeners out there on
facebook don't forget to subscribe um to
the youtube channel and uh also
if you want to participate in the
bonehead of the week poll you can go
over to twitter and follow at tony
michael's pod that's where we put up the
bonehead of the weak pole every single
week that's where bonehead madness will
live from now on not manga madness
nope
march madness nope not that one bonehead
madness
uh so go over and follow at tony
michael's pod also gabe did you know
that facebook does polls
um is there a way
i would i do they do pull i mean maybe
i i don't know i'm not on facebook that
much but someone said in the comments
today um i forget who it was and uh
don't don't uh kill me for not
remembering the name but someone said
someone said that yes the the polls over
on facebook exist so we might have to
talk to the suits okay
to see if we can coordinate i mean yeah
if we want to if we want to get a poll
going on different platforms you know
like i know that you can do someone else
mentioned uh polls on youtube i know you
can do that so you know
thomas thomas is the one that said that
thank you thomas yes so yeah there's
twitter facebook and youtube we could
run a poll on and can we do a poll on
youtube i didn't know that i don't know
yeah so we can yeah we can uh we can run
a poll on youtube uh so next next time
maybe i should subscribe to the youtube
channel
maybe i wouldn't know that if i
subscribe yeah i know that one's a good
one maybe i should subscribe to the
youtube channel i would know that a lot
better i know for anyone who's just
listening to the podcast you should
definitely watch it because there are
some visuals in here that we're reacting
to and it is trippy yeah that was good
here here's another good subscribing bye
whoa reminds me of like the 1950s batman
right
you know
yeah he's ah can you imagine that
[ __ ] standing in front of a
mirror practicing he totally has the
[ __ ] video going and he is practicing
oh yeah no [ __ ] way this guy is not
practicing practicing impersonating
donald trump
and here's the other way you couldn't
convince me you you think that he's just
pinching the thumbs right and he's got
the like fingers up but he's just like
i think maybe donald trump is throwing
like white supremacy signs you think
that the whole the whole white power
thing like right like he's like waving
house
type [ __ ] yeah yeah there's another
person i'd like to get on this show kyle
if you're listening crying kyle yeah
crying kyle rittenhouse come on the show
buddy we'll talk it out he's real upset
that yeah and didn't call him
and you know what i think you know we've
got some connections with the white
house so if he wants to come on and read
out his letter to what joe biden would
say
we'll go hand delivered ourselves
absolutely we could we could probably
connect you up
we could get the feed right into the
office of the president i know i know
the president watches our show i mean i
don't know for sure
i'm sure he'd why wouldn't he really
yeah right i mean why wouldn't he i mean
this is this is groundbreaking [ __ ] you
know the end of the week bonehead
madness i mean this is important stuff
i've yeah i'm you know what's crazy you
know that joey voted during the games
but i think joe biden voted during games
you know what's crazy about that they
were surmising this
is that it's it's kind of hard to
believe that it's it joe biden does not
watch our show folks he does not give
two shits about it i don't know i don't
know what uh but what i'll say what i'll
say is the last presidential was doing
[ __ ] like that
he was doing [ __ ] like that he would be
watching
nonsense like we're doing yeah like
we're we're providing you a way to
cathartically get out your
political frustrations that you do
throughout throughout the week just to
talk about the topics to rant about the
topics to know how to message around
those topics when you're talking to your
family your community members
but the
the former president united states was
watching that sort of content on the
right when he was pressing the red
button getting his diet cokes watching
fox and friends calling up
talking to john hannity do you think he
would go to the sex
the sex orgies i know we're over time
here but these are like
do you sorry are you sorry do you mean
do you think he was invited or do you
think he would want to go or do you
think he just showed up on advice i
don't know you tell me
i think
that
trump would show up uninvited like some
people might be like oh we should invite
this guy and it like that's like a small
like sect everyone's like hell no don't
invite dad [ __ ] yeah and they're
like oh god no oh i don't want that oh
no right uh
and i think
i think he might have been like somebody
might have like tried to sneak him an
invite and then
or he wasn't invited and he goes i
didn't even want to go to that orgy
anyway like that's the type of uh of
mentality he would have okay so so he
would probably not be invited but when
finding out that he wasn't invited to
the sanctuaries that was happening he
would claim that he didn't want to go
anyways because he throws the best the
biggest and that's not what it is right
or or it's that same type of like i did
you didn't fire me i quit you know it's
like you know it's like
the claim that it's like oh you didn't
uh invite me he's like no no you invited
me i just decided not to go
and it's just complete revisionist
storytelling but that's exactly how his
mind works when he doesn't get invited
or he doesn't get the thing that he
wants
he then just projects and says oh
actually uh i just didn't want it or i
didn't want to go or or i actually was
offered but i said no
well i think you're right i think you're
right but the thing is is if you want
evidence and i know chris is still here
listening because chris listens all the
way to the end and we appreciate that
chris if you want evidence of um
you know look at that i don't know if
that's what he's talking about for our
show but i'm going to use it as a
testimonial absolutely it is it is
entertaining even our even our trolls
think we're entertaining
what i'll say about the whole insulin
drug thing because it kind of ties into
the the drug field orgies i think maybe
that's why
maybe that's why they don't want insulin
so cheap so that that insulin doesn't
become you know a thing because i mean
with these 67 year old old republican
wrinkly nut sacks in washington they
wouldn't have cocaine fueled orgies they
may have insulin field orgies maybe
maybe that's the thing but i will say
there is evidence out there of donald
trump and and jeffrey epstein if
everyone knows who jeffrey epstein is at
a party at mar-a-lago
and what seems to be
what seems to be what donald trump would
want
yeah i mean they were there and uh
epstein was just pulling out the young
girls on the dance floor and donald
trump is like yeah yeah baby
yeah yeah you want to hit insulin
jeffrey you want to hit insulin i hear
it's i the trump insulin is really cheap
chris in yeah i it is this is a good
insulin cheap as water baby that's what
trump said
oh [ __ ] everyone please join us next
week monday through friday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific right here on
youtube twitter twitch and also
on the facebook page of midas touch we
are on the books
of
face folks
we are there we are there so don't miss
it every single weekday next week and
until monday have a great weekend and
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking